kind of risk-averse in some ways like I
don't driving fast like driving fast in
cars because I was driving very
carefully here because the roads are bad
yeah and then I think but I'm very like
Pro risk in other ways like being really
exposed to like a wide variety of people
who might hate you and I think like from
the outside that might look fine but I
think the monkey brain is really
sensitive to lots of people yelling at
you for whatever problems that you seem
to have so that's the big risk you're
taking is putting yourself out there as
an intellectual like through your
writing and then a lot of people yelling
at you is that is that the worst
embarrassment it's pretty bad yeah I
think I think the worst embarrassment is
if I put something out there that I
failed to like be properly skeptical of
in myself
and then people are like oh we caught
this thing that you didn't catch I think
that's the biggest Terror yeah from
looking at your reading and listening to
your interviews
you seem to be very defensive and
worried about being good scientists yeah
definitely well you're like methodology
yes
and funny enough you get attacked on
that methodology even though
you know of I'm a fan of psychology of
like the academic psychology and it's
it's kind of disappointing often how
non-rigorous their work is how small the
sample size and so on and how big and
ambitious over ambitious the the
proclamations about results is
especially with the news reports on it
now you're both the researcher the
scientist And the reporter right so like
that's what you have with the blog your
sample size is often gigantic
the methodology is right there the data
is right there you provide the data and
then you're like
raw and honest with your interpretation
of the day like there's of honesty
authenticity to it so I don't it's
actually really refreshing I don't know
why people criticize it I think this is
what peop this is what psychologists are
probably terrified about being
transparent and
transparent in that way is because
they'll get attacked for their
methodology so they want to cloak it in
a um
in that sort of layer of authority like
I'm from this institution it was peer
reviewed this kind of all these layers
and I'm also not going to share the data
with you and I'm also going to pretend
like most psychology studies are not
replicable I'm just going to pretend
there's authority to it I think it works
a lot of people like from the outside
you're like ah the scientists with the
white lab coats with credentials those
are the people who are like doing
science and like doing science is you
know you have like fancy terms that
other people don't really understand and
to be fair like I I have a lot to learn
I'm still like I'm self-teaching I'm
like learning through people learning as
I go I'm definitely not super
knowledgeable about this stuff
um but a lot of what those people are
doing in science is not that hard
um and a lot of people like don't try to
learn it because it seems so like
elevated and this is one thing that
really bothers me I think like everybody
can do science like if you just have
this aspect of curiosity and like you
just really want to figure something out
you can go and start you know asking
people questions doing surveys like
writing down the answers and the you go
learn how to look at that data in a way
that gives you more information about
the world like it's very simple and
straightforward if you just approach it
humbly and earnestly and you're like
please let's look let's figure this out
together but people like are think
self-crippled in this because uh they
view this as like
relegated to the domain of the experts
and you know the fancy scientists and I
think that makes me feel really sad
you're almost attracted to the questions
you're not supposed to ask oh yeah also
yes which might contribute to the
controversy not exclusively probably I
don't know you're just not limited by
like part of your curiosity is asking
questions that seem common sense like
what some of the most controversial
questions are like around sex it's like
everybody thinks and talks and does sex
I mean it's it's the driver of human
civilization and yet there's so little
like a rigorous discussion about the
like the philosophical and the
scientific questions around it it's like
it gets really weird
to be able to discuss them it becomes
tricky to discuss them yeah supercharged
super because everybody has a really
strong opinion like whether or not you
know pornography is damaging to society
or like how sex corresponds to gender or
like what kind of sexuality is
acceptable like do can you have sexual
preferences that in them in themselves
are immoral uh people get very angry
about it well the sad part
is they're not just opinionated but most
of us our relationship with sex is a
I think I guess I want to say not
rigorous
I think it's very difficult to be
rigorous about sex like and I I would
consider uh sexual urges to be kind of
elusive to introspection in a way that's
a little bit disproportionate to a lot
of other things like you could like you
know introspect about you know how I
want other people to like me and
um how where my insecurities lie but sex
is one of those black box things a
really common thing is for people to if
you have a fetish you sort of check back
in your childhood to see an event that
corresponds to that fetish and then you
like develop a narrative like ah this
event in my childhood must have caused
this fetish and so I think this causes
people to be biased towards like a like
a concrete coherent causative way that
events happen or there's that sexual
fetishes happen
um this is just like one example of like
why I think it's really hard to be
rigorous with introspection because we
can't avoid you just want to tend
towards making like coherent narratives
which I think is not always the correct
way to explain it